bring up that cover again because it
seems to me like a good place to start
this code on the cover what does it say
I can't I mean unfortunately the
definition isn't good enough for us to
be able to read it I can tell you
because I wrote it yes did it it defines
an issue it uses the e use as a
programming language called Python 3 and
it creates an R it is there it is and it
creates a class ignore that but it
creates a thing called an issue and then
it actually meaning a magazine issue and
then we go ahead and create one in the
code below we say make an issue called
bloomberg businessweek it's 599 there's
some little notes in there like for the
programmer for later like come back and
figure out other currencies because I
wanted it to be realistic and so it's
kind of incomplete imperfect code but it
runs and when you run it it publishes
Business Week I want to talk about why
this is important to talk about and
explain our own chief content officer
Josh chair and go wrote to us in a
summary this piece originated from my
own ignorance I've been faking my way
through web meetings for 12 years
comprehending some things and being
completely bewildered by others not
acceptable anymore I my brother feel the
same way so walk us through this what
does it even mean to code yes to cook
beside the fact that we want all of our
children to do it when a programmer
starts their day they come in they might
have a meeting talk to other programmers
about all the little pieces that they're
working on and then eventually they're
going to go to their computer and
they're going to sit down and they're
going to write scritch scritch scritch
they're going to write little lines of
code individual lines individual
commands and then they're going to try
to compile or execute them to make them
all run and the as enough people do that
and work together and merge all those
little things together that's how
software is born and creating a what an
appt a desktop app a website a back-end
for a website that lets you log into the
web okay so take us back a hundred years
104 yes any of this existed okay explain
to me in like pencil and paper and rock
and and chisel what the equivalent would
be oh my goodness well that's the thing
this is all new we are in we are in a
new world um but
back then it would be I would come in
and I would make some notes on a note
card and I would go put that in the
giant index card database and then
someone else would update the would
update the index to all the indexes and
then answer like to think about a giant
library well what would I think I get
your question it's my question to what
would today's coder have done 50 years
ago or 70 years ago before the advent of
the computer this is the thing it's so I
think about this question constantly
like like it there's no real answer
because the whole new motor is a highly
evolved form of human life not more
highly evolved but they really exist in
reaction to the technology so librarian
mathematician I mean the work computer
actually does refer to a human being
that was the original computer with
someone who would sit and do
mathematical operations one who computes
exactly and they would have many of them
in a room doing complicated equation
here's another question they say doctors
shouldn't run hospitals because doctors
are good at making people get better
they're not good at running
organizations what about coders should
coders run companies or should managers
run companies is it fair to say that a
coder can't be a manager why does a
coder have to be a one dimensional purse
for the same reason that most doctors
are crappy managers true but some
doctors are good is something I traders
are bad at running banks this is this is
a problem that's been going on in the
industry forever which is the
programmers get promoted because they
want to level up and they were great
coders but they're terrible with people
and it's just a well-known problem some
people are natural managers they find
their way up but very often it's a it's
a tricky situation because people sort
of get caught they want to keep
programming and then they need to move
up and they become I mean honestly
welcome to Wall Street I'd like to
introduce you to my friend John corazon
I mean thank you I guess what what sort
of in the back of my mind is Mark
Zuckerberg you know who presumably still
calls himself a programmer but who
recognized that he needed some of the
bedside manner perhaps that he lacked
and got some from chef I remember I mean
that's the thing it's he has enough
self-awareness to know i need an adult
and that's Hugh Ellyn got some got many
adults we have to leave what's your
biggest take away in this piece 30,000
words what are the 15
words I need to know learn about the
agile methodology talk which is a way of
managing coders just google it search
learn the programming language python
spend 22 hours learning it just the unit
all it takes and talk to your coders now
it takes a lot longer but get started
just get in anybody be a coder yes
anybody can he occurred yes you can
google that or you can just read this
week's issue of Business Week because
Paul crushed it Paul our friend he's a
programmer he's a journalist and this is
a really really special piece
congratulate thank you so much